man that would suck if you [ __ ] had
your house appraised and then the news
came out when actually it's like it's
divide that by ten that's the real value
that's what the zillow's estimate told
me
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we've got the Donald in the
news again he's back he's back Donald
Trump is being a sued
for financial fraud by the state of New
York and the state of New York wants 250
million dollars
been sued by New York in the past during
like his [ __ ] real estate days this
is of similar reasons interesting yeah
so it's probably business as usual for
him he's like oh this they're always
trying to get me yeah they always
they're always just trying to they're
always trying to get me these guys they
don't know what they're doing but
they're always trying to get me Jason
Jenny do you have a good Trump
impression
wow in contrast to that's what you're
trying to say
that's great it's great it's it's it's
just great you're the best Trump
impression just talk about like grabbing
[ __ ] or something whatever he would
say my grandma
she has a [ __ ]
very good very good
my grandma
my brother she was supposed
to excuse me excuse me extraordinary I
got the Cadence down that's good that's
good you got what he would say down yeah
Joe what's your bottle you're gonna
rebuttal that dude I agree excellent
excellent
grandma's [ __ ] one of the best one of
the best yeah so former president Donald
Trump inflated his net worth by billions
in order to get better loans and now the
state of New York is taking him to court
over it seeking 250 million dollars and
penalties for his children too wow New
York's attorney general Leticia James
announced the lawsuit Wednesday morning
alleging Trump engaged in widespread
fraud for years to boost his real estate
holdings according to the suit quote the
number of grossly inflated asset values
is staggering affecting most if not all
of the real estate holdings in any given
year
um
she adds all told Mr Trump the Trump
organization and other defendants as
part of a repeated pattern and common
scheme derived more than 200 false and
misleading evaluations of assets over
the course of 10 years 2011 to 2021. the
suit says the victims of Trump's alleged
fraud were the lenders and financial
institutions that did business with him
based on those false numbers
one example oh no the banks oh the banks
got [ __ ] up the ranks in the big
lenders the hedge funds and oh no the
poor victims [ __ ] yourself
one example of Trump's alleged inflation
of his assets focuses on his Mar-A-Lago
estate it's not that expensive guys
according to the suit the south Florida
property quote should have been valued
at about 75 million dollars but it was
valued at 739 million dollars can
someone explain 10x that's a lot is that
his fault or is that the [ __ ] like uh
appraisers
like he would pay him anyways I feel
like Trump will pay him to be like oh 10
exit anyways this might be a dumb
question but can someone explain to me
what Mar-A-Lago is yeah what is that is
it like a country club it's just his
estate but he named it I heard there's a
I heard there's like a like a membership
I thought it was a resort can't you like
go and yeah
like what's the point of it is like a
country club how have we never really
thought about it is it kind of like um I
thought it was a resort it's a club hold
on it's uh like a private Resort it's
like a private golf course who came up
with that of course what does that mean
I have so many questions it's a good
name it's a good name welcome to the
Mar-A-Lago club the crown jewel of Palm
Beach uh if I say
one of the most highly regarded private
clubs in the world located within 20
acres of perfectly landscaped Gardens
with ocean views Mar-A-Lago is truly the
crown jewel of Palm Beach and an
acknowledged landmark in the National
register of historic places members
enjoy all the finest amenities that the
club has to offer from an incredible
Beach and pool facility to the spa and
fine dining as well as world-class
energy that's some high society I feel
like that's like Epstein Island but on
local legally local legal and just for a
bunch of big wigs it says in addition
Mar-A-Lago is the perfect setting for
special events holiday celebrations
weddings and Galas so public events can
happen there and it seems like there's
homes in there too so is it like a
country club but there's also homes in
there because he owns a home in there
right I believe so it says he's got the
documents 85 the Trump family has spent
many weekends and holidays at their home
away from home so it's probably not
their like primary residence but it's
their like estate man that would circuit
view [ __ ] had your house appraised
and then the news came out when actually
it's it's divide that by 10. that's the
real value that's what the Zillow
zestimate told me
nobody gets mad [ __ ] the zestimate
said it was
[Laughter]
type in Mar-A-Lago price that would suck
so bad dude make you feel like an idiot
you should just type in Mar-A-Lago on
Redfin or something Zillow or whatever
what's the mortgage that's gonna be like
C dude that's got to be like I mean it
is already staggering if you had a 500
000 house and they're like actually it's
50 000. in this [ __ ] frame 750
million if he really believed that they
were like bro it's 75 million that's
[ __ ] huge that's a gigantic ass loss
that's a big discrepancy and I like how
they're thinking that he's sitting there
with a pencil going
750 million dollars like if he's true
like he's riding all of this in put
another zero on off my whole nation's
GDP
I was looking up uh like some of the
more Ballin homes in La and I saw I was
like oh like to rent what's like the
most expensive home to rent the one I
found it was uh
I think it was like 70 G's a month or
something to rent I'm like what the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] crazy I wonder if it's like
foreign billionaires diplomats or
whatever like when they do Airbnb that's
what they do because they're like I need
to be in a uh America for like or La for
like a couple months but I need to have
my house I need my like crew I need
because you know like they travel with
like a whole team with the staff yeah
yeah that shit's crazy dude we renting
expense remember like when [ __ ]
YouTube popped off for the first gen and
they were renting like I just remembered
people lived in like 25k a month
apartments and I was like that's crazy
are you [ __ ] serious
it's a tons overhead I mean at that
point though you're probably like at the
end of the year you got to spend this
money or get taxed on it you know yeah
that's like only fans girls where they
get crazy apartments and [ __ ] because
they're like what else I mean this the
cost of business is really low it's a
really nice set though so they got to
write it off somehow gotta write it off
with that really good ring light only
fans is one of the best business models
out there the margins are outrageous
dude it's just free titties and then
[ __ ] billion dollars the only cost is
you the only cost is yeah your your
reputational expense but nowadays it's
it's it's kind of it's all good
fine yeah it's over saturated now it's
got to be really tough not for Christian
men fan people you know what I mean back
in the day there was only like so many
titties that you could recognize and now
there's like a huge spread now you're
like cheesing on holy fans I guess
they're letting anybody do holy fans
that's why if they really are letting
anybody do them yeah that's the business
model yeah it works it works out great
uh New York State wants Trump's kids to
pay a price as well the lawsuit seeks to
Bar Donald Trump Jr Ivanka Trump and
Eric Trump from being officers of any
company in the state what about Baron
that's the tall kid right that must feel
like a dish to not be in the
lawsuits what about me yeah and Trump's
attorney Alina Haba denies any
wrongdoing on the former president's
part and says the lawsuit is quote
neither focused on the facts nor the law
rather it is solely focused on advancing
the Attorney General's political agenda
which I think is a very great
a lot of [ __ ] people inflate their
assets to get better loans it happens
all the time it's it's normal business
like [ __ ] and when they get caught you
got to pay for it yeah it's a little
[ __ ] oopsie pay a fine right
oopsy-doopsy oofy doofies they'll do a
deal eventually at the end of it where
it benefits the [ __ ] state of New
York somehow on the back end and they'll
let them go yeah I mean if New York if a
state at the end of the day is getting
like you know they settle let's say
they're looking for 250 million they
sell it'll settle at what
40 million yeah 25 million pull it even
yeah you know they always do that just
like wait for him to make another
mistake file another lawsuit because at
the end of the day you go against the
people who have money and that's just
part of the game you play yeah it's the
game you're playing it's like SEC it's
like stock trading like you get caught
oops or here's the [ __ ] money sorry
yeah that's how they make money that's
how the state makes money that's how the
regulatory Neo just wants to cut they
just want to cut of your these Mobsters
it's a Shakedown literally yeah Jason
Jenny have you ever been shooken down
before anything shaken down by the
government or just a random bystander
you ever been shaken down yeah you're
gonna shaken up no but I remember
um
uh somebody borrowed 15 from me wow and
um
he didn't give it back
did you pursue legal action no
we went to court for years
[Laughter]
I wanted to tell him to give me back but
was it David back yes it was David damn
it David why are you taking my 15 yeah
that's all I had you know yeah but I
thought people would always give you
back the money when was this it was in a
a uh you got shaken down bro do you know
his first and last name do you wanna do
you want to say it to him right now just
in case yeah be like hey oh
hey Thiago you owe Jason Cheney dude 15
15 bucks never forget and you gotta
calculate inflation too so now it was
probably 75 000.
that's about right actually don't ever
lend money you're not willing to give up
yeah I learned that later
[Music]
[Music]